John we had a question come in from mr.
mo net and mr. mo asks about writing
genres in television what does someone
need to know about mixing them is why
you couldn't ask a bigger question than
that it's a great question but it's a
very big question knowing your genre is
extremely important in television just
as it is in film because the genre that
you're working in gives you the primary
beats the unique story beats that must
be in your script if you're going to be
doing that show properly now as I
mentioned before television now covers
all of the major genres from detective
and crime all the way through the
fantasy science fiction horror soap
opera legal drama doctor drama so on and
these all work in radically different
ways each of those genres has its own
set story beats and this is why in all
of the classes that I teach including
the television class I spend a great
deal of time going through all the beats
of each one of those genres in the case
of television though it's also this I
wish it was simpler but it's not
but in television is not just knowing
the beats of that particular genre that
you're working in it's also
understanding how those beats are
changed by the fact that is it on
television not in film because keep in
mind again the difference the primary
difference is in film we've got a
two-hour unit that's all we have to do
with TV the key feature is what I call
extendibility we need to be able to take
a story form and extend it not only over
one season potentially 24 episodes of
one season but over five seasons so it's
got to be and that that changes the
genre itself because then what you can
do in that genre is very different when
you're having to do it in two hours
verse
is over five years
you